if you could give any character in Game
of Thrones a hug who would it be and why
I think after episode 10 I think it'd be
Tyrion just like me I'm sorry because
that's been a tough APUs owed and if you
could be had any character in the show
who would you give the chop to um Cersei
she is like next on the on the list for
aria um yeah just a nasty piece of work
really behaved Littlefinger for what
he's done to my character
I guess he's already been beheaded but I
was going to say Ned Stark for taking
away the love of my life so she needs to
go oh my god she just does nothing but
complain and whine who've had enough
princess area she was nasty to Ross with
needle the head would have been Joffrey
but he's gone that mountain I want to
take his head off ten times over for
killing my over yeah absolutely
behead Ramsay just because he's on a
sniff he saw on everyone's gonna hate me
but Jon Snow oh no I don't know why I
just he's got to go
he doesn't know anything no he doesn't
know anything so controversial I kill
Danny yeah I have a problem with Danny's
side of the story just because I just
want her to get on some boats and cross
the sea instead of having a problem with
what it's like to rule a kingdom I think
I'd like to behead Petyr Baelish Aiden's
wonderful and a lovely lovely guy and
you know it's a testament again to his
acting I don't see some well sy chopped
off must be so funny watching jump run
to get the head of Melisandre
because no one likes her I would behead
Walder Frey I'm still a little bit sore
from the word wedding Ramsay snow behead
goodbye god bless off you go
jog on in a weird way some of the sort
of characters who do some of the more
dastardly evil things probably just need
a hug to me like I feel sassy need some
affection in her life I'd hug Brienne
just to let know like from the afterlife
let know that still thinking of her and
her support for Renly
Sansa you know she's she's really not
had a good time over on Arya Arya so I
growing up very quickly I think if
something took her aside and gave ricado
that would mean quite a lot I definitely
like to give Jon Snow a hug because he's
so sad I just really like to tarimov I
think actually I deserve a hug I think
he goes through a lot and he doesn't
deserve it his Gary thanks you know no
one ever says thank you not even brown
so he deserves a hug I think it was
after he rec on cuz he left Brown and
you know it's all pretty soft
Hodor was in a really bad way so I'd
give him a hug probably Sansa rather
than hold on oh and then hot no I would
probably to give her a hug because she's
had a really tough time I would love to
give a hug to Sansa Stark I think I
would like secretly to give a hug to
Tyrion because he gets so hard done by
I love Margery really she needs a break
she's been going through the ringer and
she always sort of sits so closely to
something really awful and evil see on
because as horrible as he was like just
as horrible as he was like still I don't
think anyone deserves to go through that
torture I'd give varies Lord varies a
hug I think I like it
Aria I think she's just you know Maisie
Williams as a fantastic actress and and
I think she's been through a great deal
recently you Tyrion I Terry is great and
wonderful character wonderful wits
I would definitely hug Margaery Tyrell
she's my number one her for Queen all
the way I want to hug a white Walker I'd
like to see a thin hug a white Walker
that would be hot TV